in this video we're going to be going
through 14 verifying trigonometric
identity problems I want to challenge
you to see how many of these can you get
right on your own put the answer down in
the comment section below
let's jump into the first one we've got
cosecant squared theta minus 1 divided
by cosecant squared theta and we want to
show or prove or verify that it equals
cosine squared theta so the first thing
you want to do when you tackle these
identities is you want to look at which
side is like larger or more expanded or
complicated and then we'll work with
that side and we'll condense it down to
the side that's more condensed or
compact so in this case it clearly seems
to be the left side that's more expanded
so let's start there we've got cosecant
squared theta minus 1 whenever I see the
squared okay trig functions I always
think of these three Pythagorean trig
identities right here it doesn't always
have to be these but oftentimes it's
helpful to use these so here we have
cosecant squared if we subtract 1 from
both sides
see how cosecant squared minus 1 equals
cotangent squared so we can go ahead and
make that replacement so we're gonna
replace cosecant squared theta minus 1
with cotangent squared okay and this is
all over cosecant squared theta and
we're trying to verify or prove that it
equals cosine squared theta so the next
thing I want to do is when I look at
cotangent squared you can see that
cotangent equals cosine over sine
but if cotangent is squared then we're
going to square this side as well it's
going to be cosine squared over sine
squared let's go ahead and replace that
numerator with cosine squared theta over
sine squared theta and then cosecant
squared theta we know that cosecant is 1
over sine but if this is squared this
will be 1 over sine squared so let's
replace that so when you're thinking
about identity is really you know these
quantities they're identical we're just
interchanging one with the other so
we're not really changing the problem
we're just changing the way that it
looks now here what we're going to do is
we've got cosine squared over sine
squared 1 over sine squared let's go
ahead and multiply the numerator and the
denominator by sine squared theta
because anything divided by itself this
is 1 right
and so what happens is this science
Squared's are going to cancel and we've
got cosine squared over 1 which equals
cosine squared theta which is what we
were trying to prove that it's equal to
it and you got okay number two see if
you can do this one on your own
remember when you were in geometry and
you had to do those two column proofs
this is kind of what this is like it's
just that we're doing with trig
functions so here when we look at the
left side and the right side which one
you think is more expanded well
definitely the right side you can see
we've got two fractions here and here we
just have one term here so what we want
to do is we want to combine these
together into one term right the nice
thing about these is that we know what
the answer is that's the good news
the bad news is there's not one set you
know way of doing each one of these
problems but as long as you make an
identical substitution you know you're
gonna have the same quantity it's just
in a different form so definitely want
to practice a lot of these to get good
at them but here the first thing I
noticed is that you know just like an
algebra you know how to get a common
denominator we want to get a common
denominator for both these fractions
this one has a 1 minus cosine theta but
it doesn't have a 1 plus cosine theta
and this has a 1 plus cosine theta but
it doesn't have a 1 minus cosine theta
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm going
to multiply by what it's missing so here
I'm gonna multiply this by 1 plus cosine
theta and remember whatever you do to
the denominator you have to do that to
the numerator okay because that's like
multiplying by 1 here we're missing a 1
minus cosine theta so we're gonna
multiply the numerator by 1 minus cosine
theta okay so now let's go ahead and
simplify a little bit here we have a
binomial times a binomial what you want
to do is you want to multiply this
together so you have 1 times 1 which is
1
you have cosine theta and negative
cosine theta which cancel and then we
have cosine theta times negative cosine
theta which is negative cosine squared
theta and now what I'm going to do is
when I combine these together since they
have the same denominator now we're
gonna put it all over this common
denominator in the numerator we have 1
plus cosine theta and then over here we
have 1 minus cosine theta okay now keep
in mind you want to keep one eye on the
left side one eye on the right side we
know where we want to go to so we want
to make sure we're heading in that right
direction but at this point we're just
trying to simplify our condense as much
as we can so here you can see I've got a
cosine theta and a negative cosine theta
those cancel here we've got 1 plus 1
which is 2 over 1 minus cosine squared
theta now remember when I said you see
these ones with the second degree the
squared ones I always think of these
three Pythagorean trig identities
well that's what we have here we've got
1 if I subtract cosine squared theta
from both sides of this equation it's
still going to be an identity it's still
going to be equivalent but now we have
sine squared equals 1 minus cosine
squared so let's replace this
denominator with what it equals which is
sine squared theta ok now we're almost
there you notice the sign is in the
denominator right so you can see that
this is actually sine squared so you can
think of this as 2 times 1 okay 2 times
1 is still 2 but look one over sine
squared we know is going to be cosecant
squared so this is going to equal 2
cosecant squared theta and that's what
we were trying to prove there was equal
to and you got our 3 see if you can do
this one we've got cotangent squared
theta plus 1 times sine squared theta
minus 1 and we're trying to show that
equals a negative cotangent squared
theta so when I was learning this in
school myself you know my teachers they
would say if you don't know what to do
just do something just make some type of
substitution if it's the wrong one
meaning it you know maybe it gets more
complicated you can always back up a
couple steps and start over and try a
different substitution but don't stay
stuck you definitely want to try some
type of substitution and try to move
forward you're gonna get better as you
do these more and more and you'll start
to recognize what's going to be an
easier substitution as you get
experience so in this one again we want
to look at which side is more expanded
which side is more condensed right so
what do you think it looks definitely
like the left side is more expanded so
let's start there
now notice we've got those second-degree
trig functions right there squared again
like we've been talking about we use
these Pythagorean trig identities a lot
it's good to memorize them or you know
at least write them down and have them
in front of you so let's take a look
what we have here we've got cotangent
squared theta plus 1c cotangent squared
squared theta plus 1 we know that equals
cosecant squared theta
let's replace that with cosecant squared
theta okay now over here we have sine
squared theta minus 1 now I'll follow me
on this one see if I subtract 1 to the
left side of the equation and if I
subtract cosine squared theta to the
right side sine squared theta minus 1
actually equals negative cosine squared
theta so we're going to replace this
with negative cosine squared theta okay
now let's take a look what we have so
far it's a little bit more condensed
cosecant squared we know is 1 over sine
squared so let's go ahead and make that
replacement 1 over sine squared theta
and then over here we've got negative
cosine squared theta okay let's just
leave that as a negative cosine squared
theta another little hint is if you ever
get stuck all these trig functions are
basically made up of sines and cosines
so if you get really stuck you can
always convert back to sines and cosines
those are the basic building blocks and
you can figure it out from there but I
try not to do that
you know at the very beginning if I can
avoid it I try to use some of the other
identities first but that's always the
last kind of bet that you can use so
we've got negative cosine squared theta
over sine squared theta and now let's
take a look what we have we cosine over
sine is cotangent but these are both
squared this is going to be cotangent
square because both sides are squared
and we have a negative so it's going to
be negative cotangent squared theta and
you can see we've got to match so we
proved it okay number four see if you
can do this one cosecant theta plus
cotangent theta equals sine of theta
over one minus cosine theta how would
you do that one well first of all I
wanted to say that you know
congratulations most people probably
bailed already on this video because it
seems too challenging but I want to
congratulate you for sticking with it it
definitely the more you do the better
you're gonna get at it and you know I'm
here to cheer you on you know that's
what my whole channel is really devoted
to you know in athletics you know how
they have cheerleaders that are cheering
on that the athletes
well you guys are mathletes right and so
what we want to do here is we want to
improve our math skills so in this one
what do you think is the better side to
work with you really can't make a
mistake you know but and this one I'm
going to start with the right side and
we're going to try and work with that
so here what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
use a little technique called
multiplying by the conjugate
so conjugate is you change the sign in
between this these two terms of this
binomial so I'm gonna multiply by one
plus cosine theta and one plus cosine
theta and you're probably saying Mario
how did you know how to do that right
part of it comes with experience when
you see these come up over and over
again you'll recognize this as a valid
technique so let's go ahead and multiply
the denominators together first we've
got 1 times 1 which is 1 again the
inside and outside cancel we have
negative cosine theta and positive
cosine theta and then the last term's
give us negative cosine squared theta
and the numerator I'm just gonna leave
this factored as sine theta and 1 plus
cosine theta because sometimes what
happens is you're gonna be able to get
some terms that cancel in the numerator
and denominator when I look at 1 minus
cosine squared theta I see that squared
so I'm thinking Pythagorean trig
identities possibly right 1 minus cosine
squared theta will leave us with sine
squared theta so I'm going to replace
this denominator with sine squared theta
I'm gonna leave the numerator the same
sine theta times 1 plus cosine theta now
notice we've got 1 sine theta here to
sign you know sine squared theta here
are basically sine times sine so what
you can do is you can think of one of
these signs canceling with one of these
sines and we just have sine theta left
over in the denominator so now let's see
what we have left we've got 1 plus
cosine theta over sine theta what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to
actually split this up into two
fractions I'm going to say 1 over sine
theta plus cosine theta over sine theta
see I'm just like splitting it up into
two parts so let's write that down 1
over sine theta plus cosine theta over
sine theta and one of our sine theta we
know is cosecant theta right right here
so that's going to be cosecant theta
these are called the reciprocal
identities and cosine over sine theta we
know that that is cotangent theta and
you can see we've got a match so we
verified or R approved okay number 5 how
would you do this one we've got
cotangent sin - 4 theta equals cotangent
squared theta times cosecant squared
theta minus cotangent squared they
okay so that was a mouthful so I think
here I'll start with the right sign it
looks like a little bit more expanded
and the technique I'm going to use here
on this one is I'm going to actually see
this group here and see this group here
see how they have a cotangent squared
theta in common well let's go ahead and
factor that out as the greatest common
factor so cotangent squared theta and
then we're left with cosecant squared
theta minus one a nice thing about
factoring you can check your work if you
distribute back in you should get back
to your original now notice how we have
this cosecant squared theta when I have
this squared I again think of the
Pythagorean trig identities cosecant
squared minus one would leave us with
cotangent squared on the left there so
let's go ahead and replace this with
cotangent squared theta and this is x
cotangent squared theta and we've got
cotangent x cotangent when you multiply
just like with an algebra right the
rules of exponents you add the exponents
so it's gonna be cotangent to the fourth
theta which is what we have here and we
got it so some of the problems that
we're doing are a little bit more
challenging some of them are a little
bit more easier I try to get a nice mix
in here but I'd say they're you know
kind of in the middle at about the
medium level of difficulty number six
how would you do this one we've got 1
plus cosine theta over sine theta plus
sine theta over one plus cosine theta
equals two cosecant theta so definitely
the left side seems more expanded let's
start with that one
the key here would be really to combine
these into one fraction with a common
denominator you can see there's like two
terms here there's only one term here so
what's the common denominator well we
have to multiply by what's missing right
so here you've got one plus cosine theta
we need a sine theta so we're gonna
multiply top and bottom by sine theta so
that's gonna make this sine squared
theta okay and it's all over the common
denominator which is going to be sine
theta one plus cosine theta over here
we've got a sine theta but we're missing
a one plus cosine theta so we're gonna
have to multiply one plus cosine theta
times one plus cosine theta which is one
plus cosine theta the quantity squared
okay because the same thing twice and
this is added so now let's go ahead and
simplify this out if we foil this out
one plus cosine theta times one plus
cosine theta we get one plus two cosine
theta
plus cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta all over our common
denominator sine theta times one plus
cosine theta now cosine squared plus
sine squared that's your basic
Pythagorean trig identity that's going
to equal one so we can replace this here
with one and notice we also have one in
one here so let's go ahead and combine
those together to two so we've got two
plus two cosine theta over sine theta
one plus cosine theta now notice we can
factor out a two here in the numerator
so this is two times one plus cosine
theta all divided by sine theta one plus
cosine theta and see the numerator and
denominator that 1 plus cosine theta
cancels we have two over sine theta
which is equal to two cosecant theta and
we've got a match and you've proved it
okay let's try some number seven and
number eight these are a little bit
easier
we've got cotangent of PI over 2 minus
theta times cotangent of theta we want
to show that it equals one when you see
this pi over 2 minus theta or 90 minus
theta these are called KO functions now
let's go down here to the bottom it's
cofunctions cotangent of PI over 2 minus
theta is equal to tangent of theta so
let's go ahead and replace this with
tangent of theta times the cotangent of
theta now we know that cotangent and
tangent are reciprocals of one another
so we can replace cotangent with one
over tangent and then tangent of theta
we can just think of that as tangent of
theta over one and these are gonna
cancel on the diagonal their numerator
denominator we get 1 over 1 which is 1
and we've proved it 1 equals 1 okay try
number 8 now negative sine of negative
theta divided by negative cosine of
negative theta we want to show that
equals negative tangent theta now when
you see these negative angles these are
what are called even and odd identities
and that's these ones right here so the
sine of negative theta is the same as
sine of positive theta but it's
multiplied by negative 1 okay that's
this is called an odd function because
it's the opposite right but we have this
negative here so we've got negative sine
of negative theta we said is negative
sine positive theta
okay all divided by negative cosine of
negative theta so cosine of negative
theta is the same as cosine of positive
theta so this is going to be cosine of
positive theta multiplied by this
negative here in front and now you can
see a negative times a negative that's
gonna be a positive a positive divided
by a negative is going to be a negative
and sine divided by cosine is tangent so
we've got negative tangent of theta
equals negative tangent of theta and we
proved it okay number nine see if you
can do this one
you've got cosecant to the fourth theta
times cosecant theta cotangent theta
minus cosecant squared theta times
cosecant theta cotangent theta and we
want to show it equals cosecant cubed
theta times cotangent q theta so this
one's a real large one definitely the
left side is more expanded than the
right side and what I'm going to do on
this one is factor out the greatest
common factor so you can see that this
whole thing is a group this whole thing
is a group we want to see what they have
in common let's start off with what's in
front here we've got cosecant squared
theta cosecant to the fourth theta so we
can factor out a cosecant squared theta
also look what's in parentheses you got
a cosecant theta cotangent theta so
let's also factor out a cosecant theta
cotangent theta and if we do that we're
gonna be left with this cosecant squared
cosecant squared theta minus one okay
because we factored out this whole thing
here so we're just left with one here we
factored out cosecant squared so we were
just left with cosecant squared when we
divided this out of here so now look
what we've got we've got cosecant
squared theta minus one if we subtract
one from both sides of this Pythagorean
trig identity you can see we're going to
be left with cotangent squared theta and
now let's see what we've got we've got
cosecant squared times cosecant to the
first that's going to give us cosecant
cubed here we have cotangent to the
first times cotangent to the second that
gives us cotangent cubed and we've got
it so that was an easy one once you've
factored out the greatest common factor
number ten how would you do this one one
plus cosine theta times one minus cosine
of negative
you know we want to show that equals
sine squared theta so definitely easier
to start with on the left side it's more
expanded you can see we've got a
negative angle so we're thinking of our
even and odd identities the cosine of
negative theta we know is the same as
cosine of positive theta okay so this
whole thing is going to be cosine
positive theta and we still have one
minus and this over here is one plus
cosine theta and now if we foil this
together one times one is one cosine
theta and negative cosine theta those
cancel and then cosine theta times
negative cosine theta is negative cosine
squared theta you can see we've got that
squared cosine so we can think of our
Pythagorean trig identities 1 minus
cosine squared equals sine squared and
we proved it ok number 11 how would you
do this one sine theta times tangent
theta all over 1 minus cosine theta
minus 1 equals secant theta all right so
on this one you can see the left side is
more expanded we want to condense it
down to secant theta but what I have
here is I've got two groups two terms
separated by this minus sign so what we
really want to do is combine them into
one group by getting a common
denominator
Loosli are common denominators going to
be 1 minus cosine theta so I'm going to
multiply the numerator and denominator
by 1 minus cosine theta so that gives us
1 minus cosine theta over 1 minus cosine
theta ok and because we had a common
denominator just can extend this
fraction here sine theta and tangent
theta is sine theta over cosine theta
right here tangent theta so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to do a little
bit of simplifying here I'm gonna
distribute the negative and sine theta
is like sine theta over one so I'm gonna
multiply the numerators and denominators
so I get sine squared theta over 1 times
cosine is cosine theta minus 1 ok and
then a negative times a negative gives
you plus cosine theta all over the
common denominator 1 minus cosine theta
and keep in mind we're trying to show
that this equals secant theta so now
what's interesting is we have this
fraction within a larger
for action so what we want to do is want
to get rid of that complex fraction I'm
going to do that by multiplying the
numerator by cosine theta and the
denominator by cosine theta because
that's like multiplying by one so if I
distribute cosine to each of these terms
in the numerator here are the cosines
are going to cancel and that's just
gonna leave us with sine squared theta
cosine theta times negative one is
negative cosine theta cosine theta times
cosine theta is cosine squared theta and
then the denominator I'm just gonna
leave this as cosine theta times one
minus cosine theta and the reason I'm
leaving a factor is because we might get
some cancellation numerator and
denominator now notice how we have sine
squared plus cosine squared and that's
our basic Pythagorean trig identity that
equals one so this gives us one minus
cosine theta over cosine theta times one
minus cosine theta so you can see that
this 1 minus cosine theta and the
numerator denominator cancel out and we
just have 1 over cosine theta which
equals secant theta which is what we
were trying to prove see if you can do
number 12 and 13 here we've got cosecant
squared theta minus tangent squared of
PI over 2 minus theta and we're trying
to show that equals 1 so definitely the
left side is more expanded notice we've
got this pi over 2 minus theta we want
to refer to our cofunction identities
and you can see over here tangent of PI
over 2 minus theta is equal to cotangent
of theta but because this is tangent
squared then this is going to be
cotangent squared it's like we're
squaring both sides so this is going to
be cotangent squared theta
okay cotangent squared theta and this is
cosecant squared theta minus cotangent
squared theta and again when you have
these ones to the second power I like to
think of the Pythagorean trig identities
cosecant squared if we subtract the
cotangent squared over that's going to
leave us with 1 so you can see one
equals one that was kind of a quick and
short one let's try number 13 now 1 over
sine theta plus 1 plus 1 over sine theta
minus 1 we want to show that equals
negative 2 tangent theta secant theta
all right how would you do that one well
notice how we have a 1 group
here we've got two groups here we really
want to combine these into one fraction
by getting a common denominator so what
I do is I multiply by what I'm missing
I've got a sine theta plus one but I
need a sine theta minus one so I want to
multiply the numerator and denominator
by sine theta minus one so that's gonna
make this sine theta minus one over our
common denying our common denominator
sine theta plus one times sine theta
minus one which when you multiply that
out it comes out two sine squared theta
minus one and then here we're missing a
sine theta plus one so I'm going to
multiply the numerator by sine theta
plus one all over our common denominator
sine squared theta minus one now we can
see the negative one in the possible and
cancel sine theta plus sine theta is two
sine theta over sine squared theta minus
one now what's sine squared theta minus
one equal to well if we go to our
Pythagorean trig identities if we
subtract one to the left and subtract
the cosine squared to the right sine
squared minus one equals negative cosine
squared so now we have two sine theta
over negative cosine squared theta okay
so how we're going to work with this one
well what you can do is you can split
this up you can say this is two sine
theta over now cosine squared is really
like you've got a cosine theta times
another cosine theta okay so see how
that gives you back the negative cosine
squared theta but one over cosine theta
equals secant theta and sine over cosine
is tangent and two over negative one is
negative two so you proved it last one
number fourteen remember to put down in
the comments below how many of these
were able to get right let's see if we
can solve this one tangent of theta over
cosecant theta we want to show equals
secant theta minus cosine theta now
remember there's no right or wrong way
to do these you just want to stick with
one side if you decide you're gonna work
with the right show it equals the left
or start with the left to show that
equals the right either way I'm going to
start with the left on this one tangent
of theta is equal to sine of theta over
cosine theta okay and cosecant theta is
one over sine theta now remember when
you divide by a fraction
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
so if we take this one over sign and
flip it and multiply it by the numerator
that's going to give us sine squared
theta over cosine theta now sine squared
theta if we go to our Pythagorean tree
identity here we can subtract the sine
squared to the other side whoops I said
that wrong we're here subtract the
cosine squared to the other side sine
squared is equal to one minus cosine
squared so we're gonna replace sine
squared with 1 minus cosine squared all
divided by cosine theta now what I can
do is I can split this up into two
fractions 1 over cosine theta which is
equal to secant theta and I can split
this up over here minus cosine squared
divided by cosine is just gonna give us
cosine theta and we proved it if you
want to see more examples follow me over
to that video right there we'll do some
more trig identities I'll see you in the
next video